among the innovations of 1934 the
awarding of the Oscar to film editors
present tonight's award we've invited a
highly qualified gentlemen in 1940 who
is nominated as editor of Citizen Kane
years later as one of Hollywood's top
directors he won Oscars for West Side
Story and The Sound of Music
mr. Robert wise
for miles and miles of film the job of
the film editor is to assemble the best
footage to tell the story for instance
if the scene consists of a man as tuxedo
standing at a podium should he use a
close-up or how about an extreme long
shot or then again maybe a medium shot
is best in concert with the director the
editor establishes the overall rhythm of
the film and that rhythm contempt
contributes to the telling the story as
certainly as a script to music the
scenery or any other single element
among the great film editors our
industry has produced there was none
better than William Hornbeck who died
this past year at 82 films as varied as
a place in the Sun the Barefoot Contessa
I want to live a giant gained
immeasurably from the scale and taste he
put into it
maybe there's no better example of what
a film editor can do than the most
ancient of forms the Western shootout
has built Hornbeck edited for the
classic shame directed by George Stevens
starring Alan Ladd and Jack Palance and
now this year's nominees for film edit
Frank Morris and Edward Abrams for blue
thunder bud Smith and wal mulk honoree
for Flashdance ran far at least the
truth Minh Stephen a Rotter Douglas
Stewart and Tom are all for the right
stuff Sam Osteen for Silkwood
Richard March for terms of endearment
and the winner
Glenn Farley support receiving a router
that restores Amuro for the lifestyle
we wish to extend our thanks to the
members of the Academy this is truly a
beautiful wonderful moment for for each
one of us we acknowledge the tremendous
magnificent effort that went into the
making of this film we are privileged to
have been a part of it and the
experience will along live in our hearts
we must thank our marvelous beautiful we
love you Phil Kaufman director for his
leadership and dedication and for the
vision that he gave to us we thank the
lad company Alan Ladd jr. especially
Gareth Wigan for his gentlemanly
guidance concern care Hall through the
project and before I give the microphone
to my colleagues I would like to say
that we do thank our assistant editors
and apprentice editors for their
marvelous dedicated support all through
the project who kept their sense of
humor and carried us through to the end
the right circuit wired a monumental
effort on the part of a lot of people
not not all of whom we can thank tonight
but I'd like to just add to those
already mentioned our producers Robert
chartoff and Irwin Winkler who are the
first to see the possibilities for a
terrific movie in town Wolf's book and
again our director Phil Kaufman who
transformed that book into a fantastic
script and then into a fantastic movie
from which we were able to work terrific
footage and his vision carried us
throughout the editing for myself I'd
like to just thank my husband for his
unwavering support during a difficult
year and a half and my colleagues
Francis Coppola Walter Murch and bill
Reynolds without his support inspiration
I wouldn't be here tonight thank you if
I can just thank my wife Janet my
daughter Zoey
my good friend Dede Allen and Phil
Andros thank you very much
I just want to say I'm deeply grateful
and if I could never do anything for
anyone here
well anyway they had a big finish